we have a truly huge piece of breaking
news that also is not going to make much
of a difference and may even be a
misstep and I'll explain what I mean
the California governor is Gavin Newsom
Gavin Newsom has signed a bill into law
that requires any presidential candidate
who wants to be on the California ballot
for the presidential primaries to
release their tax returns really
sticking it to Trump now right except
not really so I like this in the sense
that I want Donald Trump's tax returns
I think he should release them I think
it is obvious that he has made the
calculation that whatever is in the tax
returns going public is worse than the
potential repercussions of not releasing
them which have effectively been zero
because he was elected despite not
releasing the tax returns yes there are
people still trying to get them and it's
an annoyance to Trump but ultimately he
kind of made the right decision assuming
that there's something damaging in those
tax returns so I want to see the tax
returns but there are some significant
issues with what Gavin Newsom is doing
first of all Trump won without
California Trump has no chance of
willing winning California in 2020 and
whether Trump is or isn't on the general
election ballot in California in 2020
it's not really going to matter in the
sense that the Democrat is going to win
California's electoral votes period so
mathematically this doesn't matter in
terms of the election results but maybe
more importantly this is to get on the
Republican primary okay Donald Trump is
not even going to face a serious primary
challenger maybe he would have somebody
in California but ultimately it doesn't
matter because there's no leverage here
this is merely that Donald Trump can't
be on the primary ballot in California
if he doesn't release his taxes and it's
a state he's going to lose anyway and
then lastly you also have to realize
that just because the governor has
signed something into the law doesn't
necessarily mean that it will stick it
does in principle go into effect
immediately but it's going to be
challenged in court it's not totally
clear if it is or isn't going to stick
there's an argument being made that it
violates the First Amendment because it
tries to tell political parties who
can your members vote for or not vote
for right it is the state saying to the
Republican Party and the Democratic
Party your members are not allowed to
vote for someone who has not published
their tax returns and there are legal
questions about whether that would be
allowed or not so I think that this is
really interesting but the headlines are
making a much bigger deal out of this
than it is this is not a big win for the
left
Trump was never going to win California
the laws about being on the primary
ballot Trump might not even be planning
to campaign in California other than
holding presumably some big-money
fundraisers in some of the more
conservative areas Orange County for
example between Los Angeles and San
Diego right Orange County south of Los
Angeles I believe and I hate to tell you
one other thing this is going to be used
as justification by Donald Trump to call
the election rigged against him like I
hate to bring this up it's completely
unreasonable this is not a rigging of
the election against Donald Trump but a
state taking action that might end up
refusing a sitting president a place on
the ballot is exactly the type of thing
that will let Donald Trump play to his
base by giving another example of how
look it's all rigged against me they're
rigging the entire thing against me now
there are similar proposals in other
states that would deal with the general
election if a candidate doesn't release
their taxes and it could be potentially
in states that Donald Trump would
actually have a shot at winning until
those get going this specific California
decision is sadly much ado about not
very much and it may have had the
unintended consequence of giving Donald
Trump and his cronies not only a
stronger argument about it being rigged
but it could get them to ramp up their
voter suppression efforts as well under
the guise that listen they're doing
things they believe will help them we're
doing things we believe will help us and
it will take an issue that really should
not be partisan I mean just people being
able to vote and having confidence that
their vote will be counted shouldn't be
partisan it is in the United States
we've talked about all of the ways in
which it is partisan and
something that Republicans benefit from
but if Republicans see what appears to
be a bill specifically targeting Donald
Trump via his taxes in California even
though California is irrelevant to Trump
winning again as I mentioned it is going
to convince some of those folks to look
the other way on voter suppression
efforts by Republicans which they might
otherwise call out so I don't know let
me open it to you what do you think
about this is my analysis that it is not
going to achieve anything for Democrats
and it may emboldened Trump in some ways
the right analysis do you disagree with
my analysis I want to hear from you but
bottom line I'm relatively unmoved about
it and if I'm missing something I would
love to know what that is